головна православна святиня Донбасу одна
з трьох українських лавр Святогірська
вона як і києво-печерська та Почаївська
належить УПЦ пов'язаній з Московським
патріархатом лавра розташована на
правому березі сіверського Донця а місто
святогірськ на лівому міст який
з'єднував монастир і місто підірвали у
червні торік напередодні окупації
Святогірська у вересні місто звільнили
Та нині сюди вже не їдуть тисячі
паломників туристична Перлина Донбасу
потрощена війною до монастиря
Московського патріархату який раніше був
головною туристичною принадою регіону
місцеві ставляться неоднозначно лавра
для мене це святує вона ж занесена в
книгу
батюшка приїжджає тоже помогает нам
вообще да это Московского взагалі так це
Московського Патріархату
сюди Янукович їздив Гнатик його поганим
віником звідси Я сама росіянка і я проти
цього руського мира що вони нам тут
зробили ви знаєте мені що Росія що
Україна одинакова ви знаєте мені що
Росія що Україна однаково у мене рідних
дуже багато в Росії живе у мене батько в
Росії і мама Колись жила в Росії а потім
переїхала сюди батьки захворіли і Вона
забрала нас а Батько помер давно мені
близький і Росія і Україна Ось це що
відбувається ця війна ми в шоці Всі
є і більш радикальні думки але не на
камеру оце мій я город от зараз Ви
зайшли в мій город практично а там ваш я
точно знаю що ви собираєтеся до мене
прийти і мені по морді надавати і
покрасив у мене ви вводите захищатися чи
ні ви вважаєте що Росія захищалася
естественно естественно що думають у
самій Лаврі дізнатися нелегко
журналістам тут не раді Ми не любителі
балакать девочка дорогая
ми нічого не даємо даних ні на території
є Лаври Нам дозволили перебувати лише
під наглядом місцевого охоронця Він
повідомив що клір монастиря не дає
інтерв'ю
у лаврі малолюдно повсюди сліди від
обстрілів у дворі могили загиблих через
прильоти монахів Поки святогірськ був
окупованим монастир залишався під
контролем України Утім не раз потрапляв
під вогонь священнослужитель Лаври
архімандрит Феофан який відмовився
спілкуватися на камеру не знає чиї
снаряди пошкодили Обитель також на його
думку не варто засуджувати дії Росії
розбираються хто тогда мы были Между
двух огней И пусть те которые
специалисти футболістів
ще з 2014 року у Святогірська Лавра
приймала біженців із перефронтових міст
нині тут проживають близько 200 людей
зокрема жителі довколишніх міст і сіл
які залишилися без даху над головою
блин ось рік при Росії просидів без
роботи
Ось так сидимо і думаємо хоч би не сюди
гепнуло раз пронесло добре
Віталій з ізюма і Сергій зіслов'янська
лагодять лінії зв'язку у монастирі Ось
як чоловіки описують атмосферу у
святогірській лаврі тут Как говорится
тут як то кажуть кожної тварі по парі
хтось може ближче до Росії хтось за
Україну тут на це не дивляться ляпай що
хочеш аби не робив Нічого такого
Ось у будь-яке село зайдуть і в села за
Росію і в села за Україну все
ще одна жителька Лаври розповіла як
торік люди з монастиря намагалися
перепливати річку щоб потрапити в
окупований росіянами святогірськ деяких
за її словами розстріляли жінка не на
камеру поділилася своєю версією хто
винний у цьому
дітьми переплела А когда двоє мужчин
хотели приплыть просто именно было в
Россию Ну надо у них родственники были
они расстреляли
не может пожалеели потому что все такие
Ну как бы не все ж украинцы этот Ну
украинцы ж люди Конечно есть ну вот
наверное из-за того что они не хотели
чтобы мужчины эти в армию пойдут в
Россию скорее всего у 2014 році колєр
святогірської Лаври звинувачували у
підтримці бойовиків так званої ДНР
намісник Лаври митрополит Арсеній
називав війну на Донбасі громадянською
це внутрішні це громадянська війна ви
знаєте війна виникає там де
недорабатують політики і дипломати
І от якраз недостатньо дипломатичного
бажання почути один одного стало
спровокувалась у війну у січні цьогоріч
Арсенія позбавили українського
громадянства Утім на відміну від
центральних і західних регіонів на
Донбасі поки не йдеться про заборону
пов'язаної з Росією церкви Святогірська
лавра і надалі перебуває у безстроковій
і безоплатній оренді УПЦ
А це один з небагатьох храмів пцу на
Донбасі
благословенний Бог наш завжди мені
повсякчас і на віки віків
тут служить отець Віталій який в миру
працює оператором газорозподільчої
станції
зранку прокинувся
руки ноги є
голова на місці слабо Господу Богу
і вперед і оце люди збираються тут Тому
що тут єдина Кам'яна церква у місті
Краматорську наша
все інше Це жестянки чи отакі з ОСБ
отакі от Ну якщо пролетить там живих не
залишиться а тут правила двох стін
працює бачите тут одна стіна і друга
стіна на Донеччині серед інших областей
України найбільше церков підпорядкованих
УПЦ МП на користь пцу ця ситуація поки
не змінюється
жодна парафія
в нашому регіоні не перейшла в
українську церкву
Ким би вони себе не називали
українською церквою
Единственная
православная Чи як воно там все
називається це була і є фсб-шна церква
отець Віталій єдиний священник пцу в
краматорському районі чимало духівників
виїхали з міста що за 30 кілометрів від
фронту Через це у отця Віталія щільний
графік Я займаюсь похованнями
похованнями наших полеглих воїнів по
всьому району тобто Якщо раніше це був
Краматорськ воно окреме місто було то
тепер це є Краматорський район Тобто це
майже 70 кілометрів від один бік
і якщо хтось з наших воїнів загинув то
там Більш нікому ховати Ні ну є
московиті але Зрозумійте Як Вообще можна
це виглядати якщо Москва вбила
і Москву позвали відспівувати
як би не вкладається навіть в голові за
словами отця Віталія нині дедалі більше
людей приходять до церкви це мотивує
священника продовжувати свою справу Це
моя земля
ми не сюди не завезли
я не население Я громадянин цього міста
я півроку був три роки я і моя матушка
навчалась
як боронить
як захищати як давати медичну допомогу я
цього не бажаю але якщо треба будем
захищати
будемо до останнього
Що ж до головної святині Донбасу
святогірської Лаври у пцу закликають
повернути її державі і сподіваються що
скоро там звучатимуть молитви за
український народ і ЗСУ у самій Лаврі не
на камеру Кажуть що будуть захищати
Обитель узаконний спосіб